can you put up Twitter if you can bring
up Twitter Robert Reich which you know
for a lot of people if you know who
Robert Reich is he's a
socialist that economically is always
bashing capitalists constantly if he
gets a chance to do it he does it so he
posted something yesterday and I tweeted
back I responded back go go to go to
replies and that that way it'll come up
instead of the way you're going yeah go
to replies
and go up go up let's see if it'll show
it go up one more I don't know if it's
going to show you on the third one
uh there it is that's one right there
okay go up a little bit and zoom in
perfect zoom in okay so he first show
his tweet at the bottom Robert Wright
tweet saying in 1978
CEO pay has increased 1460 percent yes
you read that correctly so don't tell me
that corporations can't afford to pay
workers higher wages and provide decent
benefits so if the average person reads
that stay on that real quick before you
go to my zoom in real close because I
don't want people to read what I said
even a little bit more go up a little
bit go up a little bit okay so average
person who reads that they say what
Wow since 1978 CEOs pay has increased by
1400 or 60 percent yes you read that
correct so don't tell me that
corporations can't afford to pay workers
Hardware doesn't provide you some
benefits what does that produce
animosity towards who CEOs animosity
Tortola who else capitalists the average
person reads this who do they hate
they're disgusted by anybody that's a
capitalist so then I pose a nice
question back to him he never responds
back to my questions I don't know why he
doesn't like my questions go up a little
bit so I can read my question Tyler if
you could so here's my question okay I
said I'd like to get your thoughts on
three additional stats average NBA
player salary since 1978 has increased 9
400 percent
College tuition has increased 1400 since
1978 and last but not least you make a
hundred thousand dollars an hour for
keynote that's more than 99.9 percent of
CEOs in America should we be concerned
so then people like well
that's uh
that's interesting I didn't know NBA
players the average NBA player in 1978
was making 40 Grand a year you know what
the average NBA player salary is today 8
million bucks really that point eight is
the average NBA player's salary from 40
Grand are you come are you happy foreign
players making 8.8 I am I think they're
fine I don't sit there and judge them
I'm totally cool I think LeBron deserves
100 million a year not 30 million you're
40 million year college tuition has
increased 1400 percent has our
intelligence improved 1400 percent has
has the education improved that much
better are kids coming out of college
right now just so much more brilliant
than they came out in 1978. I don't know
and he's getting paid a hundred thousand
dollars to do a keynote isn't a
socialist kind of shouldn't get paid a
hundred thousand dollars shouldn't a
socialist take that hundred thousand
dollars and give a thousand dollars to
each attendee who's in the room and
divided amongst the attendees that's
what the right socialist should do but
guess what Rob did right I think I'm
happy that you're making a hundred
thousand dollars an hour I don't judge
you I don't care it doesn't bother me
but you're playing games and you're
dividing and you're not telling the
other side of the story and some people
are falling for it but not anymore
people are starting to think for
themselves and this whole concept of
thinking for yourself it's starting to
become popular and cool again because
people are comfortable questioning
things today something we stopped doing
for a few years so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you